the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
video
in this video i want to go over some of
the main characters who will be featured
in this show
as you all know hbo has already hired
several actors for their upcoming series
house of the dragon
they still need to hire a lot more
actors for the show but as of right now
they have found most of their key
characters i have showed you who they
are in some of my other update videos
but now i want to go into a little more
detail about each one
one of you left me a comment on one of
my recent videos asking me if i would do
this because they weren't exactly sure
who some of these actors would be in the
show
so that's what i want to do in this
video i will explain
what each of these actors will do in the
show based on what we know so far
now as i have said before i have already
made a video where i go over all of the
major events that i think we will see in
house of the dragon
this series will be based on the
targaryen civil war after all
therefore we will see a lot of
targaryens fighting other targaryens
and a lot of dragons fighting other
dragons it should be epic
in every sense of the word since none of
us know exactly how much of george's
writing they will be adapting
i will try to keep this as simple as i
can so it's very easy for everyone to
understand
the very first actor hbo hired was patty
considine
and he will be king viserys targaryen
for those of you who don't know king
viserys targaryen was a dragon rider
not only was he a dragon rider but he
rode arguably the most fearsome dragon
in all of a song of ice and fire
that dragon is of course valeria on the
black dread
unfortunately i doubt we will see this
dragon in the show
because belarion dies before the events
they want to focus on but don't worry
there will be over a dozen of other
dragons we will see
now although he will be the king at the
start of the series he won't necessarily
be the main character
because the story is not really about
him house of the dragon will mostly be
about what happens after he dies
when his wife and children are fighting
over who gets the iron throne
it will be kind of similar to what
happened in game of thrones
when king viserys targaryen dies his
wife alison hightower
makes sure their son aegon the second of
his name gets the iron throne
the only issue is viserys did not name
his son as his heir
before viserys died he named his
daughter rhaenyra as his heir
and this is where all of the fighting
begins this is when all of the
characters will have to choose sides
do they want king viserys's firstborn
son to sit on the iron throne
or do they want his firstborn daughter
rhaenara who he did name as his
successor
this is when things get very interesting
but now i'm getting ahead of myself
so as i was saying patty considine will
be king viserys targaryen
now his first wife was emma aaron
hbo hasn't hired anyone for this role
yet so i'm not even sure if we will see
this character in the show
but i have to mention her for this to
make sense viserys and
emma were married for over a decade and
they tried their best to have a son
so viserys could have an heir but it
never happened
one day emma does give birth to a baby
boy
but not only does the baby die so does
she now viserys doesn't have a son
nor does he have a wife what viserys
does have is a brother
and a daughter viserys's brother is
named daemon targaryen who i believe
will be one of the most interesting
characters in this show
in case you don't know already actor
matt smith landed the role as daemon
this character will easily be the most
experienced warrior in the series
he also just so happens to carry his own
valyrian steel sword known as dark
sister
but this isn't all he has daebon
targaryen also has his own dragon named
karaxis
now you would think this would make
daemon a great candidate for the iron
throne
he's a skilled warrior he has a valyrian
steel sword
he has a dragon and most notably he is
the king's brother
after all viserys doesn't have a son
annie no longer has a wife to try to
make any more sons with
well you see viserys doesn't really want
daemon to be his successor
in fact he's actually not very happy
with daemon at the moment
because he made some let's just say
insensitive jokes when his wife and
newborn son died
but i'm sure you all know how that goes
you get a little drunk
your brother's wife and kid dies so you
crack a few jokes
we've all been there before so if aseris
doesn't want daemon as
the heir then who does that leave what
other options would he have right now
well he has his daughter rhaenyra
targaryen
in case you don't already know hbo hired
actress emma diarcy
and hopefully i said that right she will
be our rhaenara
daughter of king viserys targaryen now
rhaenyra is also a dragon rider
she has a dragon named cyrax rhaenyra
also has several sons
some of whom also have dragons of their
own but i won't get into all of their
names in this video
because hbo hasn't cast any of them yet
either
like i said she has her own dragon some
of her sons have their own dragons
but she also has several more dragons
just sitting around on dragonstone
waiting for writers now rhaenyra's sons
were allegedly fathered by a character
named leonor valeron
however some say they were actually
fathered by rhaenyra's lover
since hbo hasn't cast leynor valeron i'm
not sure if we're going to see him
but rhaenyra is not with him during the
dance of dragons anyway
because he's already dead by then
rhaenyra is actually in a relationship
with daemon targaryen
that's right her father's very own
brother so
although daemon might not get the iron
throne for himself
he figures he can help out reiner get
the iron throne which i guess is the
next best thing
what you should know is rhaenyra is not
daemon's only lover
daemon likes to sleep around a little
bit but i will get into that later
so where were we king viserys needs an
heir
he doesn't have a son and he doesn't
want his brother so that leaves his
daughter rhaenyra as a good option
now before viserys actually lost his
wife and newborn son
there was a character who was already
suggesting viserys should name his
daughter rhaenyra as the heir
sir otto hightower who is the hand of
the king to viserys
said he should just name his daughter
the heir now in case you don't know
hbo has found an actor for this role
hopefully i don't butcher his name as
bad as i did last time but hbo has hired
actor rhys
iphones and he will be our serato
hightower hand of the king
now like i said before viserys lost his
wife a newborn son
sir otto suggested that vasara should
name his daughter as the heir
viserys wasn't really a fan of this idea
though because he was still convinced
that his wife would give him a son
but that didn't end up happening the
reason serado was suggesting this so
soon was because he was worried
something would happen to viserys
he did not want the king's brother
daemon getting the iron throne
you see serado and daemon did not like
each other
sir otto saw daemon as a threat i
realized i did say some of this out of
order
but i don't want to be introducing a new
character in every single sentence i say
otherwise it would get very confusing if
you're not familiar with any of them
anyways as soon as daemon made those
jokes about his brother's dead wife and
son
viserys did name rhaenara as his heir
this shut daemon out viserys started
showing his daughter how to run the
kingdoms
rhaenyra was right by her father's side
learning from the king himself
but this is a song of ice and fire we
know this doesn't have any happy endings
you see king viserys was still a very
young man
he wasn't even 30 years old yet so what
happens next
viserys ends up getting married again
but this time he marries a very young
and fertile alison hightower she is the
daughter of serato hightower hand of the
king
for those of you who don't know hbo
hired actress olivia cook
who will be our queen alicent at first
rhaenyra got along very well with her
new stepmother alicent
in fact during the wedding feast alison
even kissed her
and named her daughter when daemon found
out his brother married again
he beat the brakes off the messenger he
beat him so bad he nearly killed him
and the sweet loving relationship
between king viserys's new wife alicent
and his daughter rhaenyra did not last
for very long
both of them wanted to be first lady of
the realm but there was room for only
one
everything really went downhill once
alison started giving viserys sons
he still wanted his daughter rhaenyra to
remain as his heir
so that's what happened well that is
until viserys died
so king viserys and queen alicent ended
up having three kids together
as of right now hbo has not found actors
for them yet but i'm sure they will very
soon
almost immediately after viserys dies in
his sleep
his son aegon is crowned as the king
instead of his daughter rhaenyra which
is who he wanted
aegon targaryen the second of his name
was crowned by sir kristin cole
the lord commander of the kingsguard as
well as his mother
queen allison hightower now rhaenyra is
left to fight for the iron throne her
father had left her
rhaenyra would now have to fight her own
stepmother alicent
as well as her little brother aegon who
was now the new king
since alicent wore a green gown and
rhaenyra wore the targaryen colors of
black and red
it became the custom to refer to the
greens and the blacks
or the greens versus the blacks when
talking to the two respective sides
this ultimately leads to the targaryen
civil war also known as the dance of
dragons
this fight over the iron throne would
not only lead to the deaths of almost
every targaryen in the known world
but almost all of their dragons as well
so let me show you which sides these
actors and their characters will be
fighting for
now that i've laid out the basic setup
for the story
the actor patty considine is our king
viserys targaryen
who is obviously at the head of this
mess but on the side of the greens
we have his wife queen alice in
hightower who will be portrayed by
actress olivia cook
and we have her father the hand of the
king sir otto hightower
who will be played by rhee siphons these
are the only characters hbo has cast so
far for the side of the greens
obviously there is a lot of other
characters fighting for this side
but i will discuss them further as each
one is officially announced by hbo
or another reputable source now on the
side for the blacks
hbo has cast several characters leading
this faction
is of course rhaenyra targaryen who will
be played by emma diarcy
right by her side will be her lover and
father's brother daemon targaryen who
will be played by matt
smith also fighting on their side is
lord corliss valeron
aka the sea snake and we have his wife
rhaenys valeron now these are some great
characters to have fighting by your side
the sea snake or lord corliss valeron is
the most famous
nautical adventurer in the history of
westeros
he built his house into a major sea that
is even richer than the lannisters
and that claims the largest navy in the
world
like i said in a recent video having
this man on your side is like having the
lannisters and the greyjoys combined
he has the money and the ships now his
wife
rhaenys valeron is a dragon rider and
she does fight in one of the most epic
battles during the dance of dragons
that was when her and her dragon fight
the new king aegon and his dragon
as well as his brother aim on one eye
and his
massive dragon veigar this gives
rhaenyra even more dragons than she
already had before
if you remember rhaenara has a dragon
her sons have dragons
and she has many dragons sitting at
dragonstone just waiting for new riders
and now she has rainey's dragon on her
side as well as all of her husband's
ships
not to mention rhaenyra also has daemon
on her side
an extremely skilled warrior who has a
valyrian steel sword
and a very large dragon of his own
rhaenara targaryen side
is loaded now you could list a lot of
reasons for why corliss valeron
and his wife rhaenys velaryon are
fighting for rhaenyra's side
but i think one good reason is because
they are the grandparents to rhaenyra's
children
rhaenys and her husband had one child
together who was lenore valeron
the alleged father of rhaenyra's kids
now most would say rhaenyra's sons were
fathered by another man
but we won't go down that road just yet
anyways corliss velaryon will be played
by actor steve toussaint
and his wife rhaenys valeron will be
played by actress eve
best there is one more character i must
mention who is technically on the side
of the blacks
that character is massaria also known as
lady misery
she is another one of daemon targaryen's
lovers but she also becomes the
unofficial mistress of whisperers to
rhaenyra targaryen
although she wasn't actually on her
small council what's interesting is
daemon actually gets massaria pregnant
and he gives her a dragon egg for the
child but once again
i don't know how much of this they will
cover in house of the dragon
all we do know is hbo has found an
actress for this character
so we will definitely see her in the
show to some extent
and just in case you don't know actress
sanoya mizuno
will be our lady misery masarya now this
is obviously a very rough outline of who
these characters are
but now you should have a better idea
about some of the things you can expect
to see from them
hopefully this also helps you visualize
some of these actors in their roles
if you're new around here or just not
familiar with the dance of dragons
then consider checking out my other
video linked down below
in that other video i explained almost
all of the major events that should
happen in house of the dragon
i should warn you though that video
might spoil a lot of the series for you
if you're still a little lost on any of
this let me know down below
or just leave me some of your thoughts
about the series as a whole
i'm always interested in seeing what
everyone has to say
i enjoy and welcome the feedback as
always thanks for watching my video
i hope you all have a great day i will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
you